when a top pass-rush is available in
this year's draft love watching this guy
play at the University of Michigan he is
none other than chase whatever it's good
to see you sir
it's great to be here great to see you
what thank you we're exactly good to see
you again they're back there in
Indianapolis although I stuck in a booth
I was watching you run around the field
before we get to all that you have a
favorite sir yeah without a question I
don't know how it hasn't been brought up
yet it's just disrespectful to the
cereal hmm and if I was them I'd
probably sue okay you know just a heads
up okay waffle crisps
I mean hands-down the best thank you how
can you pack so much sugary goodness
into like cereal and it just it's not
about just a cereal yeah you got a
factor in how it pairs with milk of
course and the the waffle crisp just it
pairs really good because they if it's
like kind of crunchy you know you get
like a more crispy waffle but if it's
soggy from the milk you know it also
tastes good well I've just been informed
by our courting producer Don Bowie in my
ear that waffle crisps have been
discontinued though are you eating
outdated about this I was inspired by
playing Fallout as a kid
shoutout to Bethesda and I just was
inspired by it you know so I just went
out and I just you know bought a couple
years worth of waffle crisps just you
know you got to be safe
you can't so if a team wanted to throw
you off in the interview setting at the
combine they should have just given you
that information that waffle Christmas
has been disco I don't know how to react
to years left or so but yeah I ration I
figured I could squeeze out at least
five what is the strangest question you
were asked at the combine chase one
division you know people I guess had
done some research I told myself you
know I wasn't gonna go dive into this
but it wasn't just one team asking it
was the product at least like five so
and that is I'm just asking about my
date with Madonna's daughter was
something that was brought up a bunch so
how is that immeasurable whatsoever I
think it's one of those things where you
know you go in and I felt like my
reputation and my personality like more
so my personality I had
kind of preceded me so like you know
because people see in the media and like
what you show the world is kind of
limited you know even though I was
trying to be authentic and I went in
there and I try to present you know this
this front that you know I care about
football like I'm trying to add value to
your organization in it because you only
get 15 minutes in the formal ones and
about the same and the in formals so I
try to make that impression and they you
know they came in and you know they try
to get me more so poking at that section
and of my life and the one that's like
out there kind of in the media so
madonna's daughter Lourdes yes sir okay
she went to mission she did okay and you
dated her so yeah it was a I went on a
date with her yeah okay so I it was
actually a funny story my my parents and
my family were messing with me I think
it was fresh me or Christmas yes and so
they were just give me a hard time
saying like oh you can never go on a
date with her because like they had read
an article that's saying something that
she was there and so I messaged her or I
found her email and so I emailed her and
told her I was trying to join the School
of Music Theatre and dance and so I one
thing led to another we went on a date
so that was that was about that were you
not trying to join the music dance I was
considering you know going into that but
okay so it was a want you were your
college kid trying to get a date it's
basically what you're saying right so
yeah my grandfather always gave me some
advice he said get the job and figure
out how to do it so I figured I'd I
picture on the trying to join them you
school music theater dance and learn how
to sing and dance okay but you won't
want and done that's over so yeah that's
how he was in New York City now is that
how you answer the question in the comma
we just get that's basically basically
it right yeah but you could also say
look at the tape if you want to ask
about whether I care about football I
tried to I tried real hard to make a
good impression I even was watching some
TV show and they had they thought you
know how to do magic it was like
basically like exploding fingers so you
know after the date was over and she at
one point she was like I'm hungry I was
like what do you want she's like these
appetizers look good so I ordered
every single advertiser that was
automated I was like we'll take one of
everything
so it didn't work and so it didn't work
and then we you know afterwards the
magic part was the other put this like
powder on each finger okay and then you
snap your fingers and it makes like an
explosion sure very impressive and so
we're walking outside and I had did it
and like her eyes lit up she's like whoa
like what was that it's like I was like
okay like I made an impression on her
and then she's like do it again and so I
was like I can't like it's not how that
works you should you should take a page
at a chase with a [ __ ] on your next
date to do one of those things what do
you think magic tricks I can't do it we
can't which is great for the guy who is
actually working the soundboard right
right here that he's not Gordon enough
that's wonderful
so okay so that was a strangest question
you were asked at the combine who did
you meet with at the combine so I met
with a bunch of teams I met with
basically every team informally and I
met with father around like 10 or 11
formally sit down yes it or this dealer
is one of the teams no no where you are
from I think there's a technicality with
with a like just talking to some teams
asking them like there's like I try to
be straight up with them because you
know I I expect them to be straight up
with me at least as much as they can be
strategically so I approach it you know
just asking them like the teams that did
informal interview like what's up with
that like just messing with them and
some of them would be like saying
sometimes like if you don't have any
character questions and they you know it
doesn't necessarily correlate between
getting drafted you know and having an
interview there's not like the
correlation okay you know sometimes you
just you just don't know that's just the
way the draft is okay very good but
you're from Western PA right I'm from
Western PA I'm like eight minutes or a
mile south of where the Steelers
practice and stuff so I always joke and
say if you know I would just live at
home save money on rent my mom would
make me breakfast in the morning at 6:00
7:00 in the morning
get some coffee go about my day okay is
it true growing up in Western PA you
were a Buckeyes fan is that a true fact
that is true what the hell cheese it was
one of those things were
for me Penn State was dealing with that
whole you know like the whole Sandusky
thing and it was like if I went there I
would have kind of had to associate
myself with that a new coach O'Brien was
probably gonna be leaving so like they
were kind of eliminated from my running
Pitt just not having a stadium on campus
and them not offering my brother a
scholarship I always you know felt some
some bitterness okay you know just about
that but honestly it was one of those
things where I just took a visit to Ohio
State Pitt and Michigan hmm those were
my final three and I just fell in love
with Michigan just everything about it
they showed me the Union and I still
remember it how I forget his name but he
was an engineer at Michigan or architect
and at the Union they have a pillar like
a statue of him and he's looking towards
like the football you know like the
athletic campus in his athletic garment
and then on the other side they have a
you know him but he's in his academic
gown and he's looking at the academic
campus and like for me it's like that
aspiration to be like you know the
ultimate man like the as best as you
could possibly be something I collided
with well when I got when I when I went
on campus a foot of snow fell I'm from
New York City so I've used to being in
snow but a foot of snow fell and it was
so damn cold and I still fell in love
with it too and I'm like this is the
place right about it I did feel that way
yeah I sound you know anytime I talk
about Michigan and like a propaganda
piece called meat I literally can't say
anything bad about it you and I have
been accused of being of the same thing
but you grew up an Ohio State family
okay and for me it was one of those
things where I always I grew up every
single Saturday going to you know watch
his watch I was playing football on the
sidelines and just playing my own games
mmm but I grew up going to Bowling Green
and as a falcon and you know just
growing up kind of like with that an
Ohio mentality and then terrelle pryor
went there and just see it for me like
seeing a Western PA kid just go and do
big things I'm like at a national scale
kind of inspired me and like I you know
correlated Ohio State and and you know
just coming from Western PA and being in
that spotlight so
okay so that's you just you're so
reasonable chase there's a reasonable
guy you're just laying it all out on the
line like that so I can I can accept all
of that and then of course you your love
of the University of Michigan was
confirmed when you heard a pregame
speech in September of 2016 that was a
great one by somebody who was that
person Chris Brockman do you think I
think that was you I was there you were
there right it wasn't pregame there was
it was a practice today yeah now
Harbaugh labeled it a top five was he
just would that it was at a top five
speech it was it was honest there's
there's a lot of good speeches but like
I'd say like yours in particular I liked
like what you talked about like you know
the almost like ideology of like you
know this is why you came to Michigan
like we came here with this this vision
of where things should be and it's
confirmed like you talked about that too
like you knew that when you walked into
the the football facilities and you know
you've met with Coach Schembechler yeah
coach Becker yeah just seeing how like
everything operated and it was the same
way for me like even at like Michigan's
lowest point and not making a bowl game
you know during my freshman year like
you always clung to that aspiration to
just you know be better be the best like
this this mission and so it's cool I'm
gonna put you a little bit on the spot
so many people say that Harbaugh is not
the guy to take Michigan where it needs
to be I pound the table in a different
direction you guy who's been through the
program what do you think I disagree
completely I think like being around
coach Harbaugh like a like he has so
much depth to him like if you knew him
on like a personal note like there's
there's one coach and I think I'll if
you have time I'll take you on the
inside of that sure but like on the
other note it's like he's it's just so
crafty and and you know he even admits
this like he's just even if he's not
like a creator like he's not creating
new offensive schemes like he's an
improver like he can take anything and
in most anybody and if you're willing to
buy in and drink the kool-aid as they
say I think I'm gonna you know a great
example of that I came in as a 205 pound
inside linebacker and just buying in he
was he came in my freshman year and just
buying into what he had to say and in
his mission and his speeches of
outworking everybody you know you can
you can accomplish great things so you
so we have to go on the inside you know
this is a story I haven't you know
really spoke of but you know I'm gonna
share it with you guys attaboy chase
like you know any time like going even
going into this like there's like a
mystique about coach Harbaugh going into
this meeting and it was my sophomore
year and I had pulled my hamstring so I
wasn't I wasn't playing but I was hurt
but like I was so far down like on a
like the depth chart at that point
because like I was hurt and it was in
camp and that you know coach Harbaugh
was still so invested into my success
and you know he pulled me into his
office one night called me in and it was
it was so weird I don't think a candle
was was lit but it had that it had that
feel you know like it was like the light
was kind of dimmed and he sitting there
were this tortoiseshell glasses and he
just he had such compassion and in such
like it was weird just to feel that
empathy from him and that's when I knew
like you know he really did care about
me and and that's what I came to
Michigan in the first place I didn't
want to you know I wanted that that
feeling of what I'll say to you it was
that for me it was more so the sentiment
but of like the thing but he just asked
me like you know kind of like
sympathized with my position just about
being hurt I think he reflected upon
like a story when he had broke his arm
and you know he had just just became the
starting quarterback and you know like
sometimes if you take this dip but it's
not it's not about that it's about you
know the process of coming back it's a
process of discovery about yourself and
learning and we've helped you turn it it
helped me turn a corner and it was it it
didn't happen to like immediately
because like with injuries they take
time but like eventually over time I was
able to you know kind of apply that
advice and
you when you're fighting and you're
swinging basically and you know that
like you know someone has your back in
like eventually it's gonna work out and
you have that confidence it's a great
relief chase win of a cheer and the Rich
Eisen show you've got your cap on at
winnow yep okay thank you for the create
you know valuation portion of your life
right now I don't want it to people
think at why no you're not why no but
it's nice we know is your Instagram
handle on your character okay so we're
all good on that front
yeah and I just want to say this too I
said this to you a backstage I'll say it
again at watching you play with your
your passion you could see it you could
see it and then when you were hurt maybe
before the Ohio State game me and all my
buddies are like we got to get one of
its there I mean cuz you were really a
heart and soul type player we couldn't
feel it we could sense it and I think a
lot of that has to do as well I want to
bring this to the fore what you did for
the Chad tough foundation Chad being
Lloyd cars grandson who died of brain
cancer that you dyed your hair orange
you got don brownlee not defensive
coordinator to die first Evan Bush
everybody why did you do that for me I I
was actually inspired at first off I
always wanted to give back you know that
was always kind of part of like my
greater plan was to get in this position
and and for me like whenever you're in
this position and you want to go put
yourself out there there's a lot of risk
involved because when you make yourself
a target just things go wrong and if
especially you play bad then you're the
guy that a the media is gonna be blaming
and be like if you go look at a my just
my Instagram after Ohio State games
looks like they're gonna go comment on
my picture you know this is like not a
not other people and sometimes that's
just the way it is yeah so for me like I
knew I always wanted to get back I was
inspired by this this I decide I see you
know YouTube where it's almost attacks
to be in this position you got to kind
of give back you know a certain percent
of you know just this position back into
the universe for
for being this blast and so I reached
out to some different people about you
know kind of doing a partnership with
them during the season and I'm pretty
creative which is with my ideas and
Tammy car was a perfect fit because a
they don't get a lot of government
funding so everything that we did would
have a pretty profound impact and like
that money was like it was needed and
like the efforts like this and be it's
you know Michigan and see like they're
just great people Tammy cars one of the
best people I know and I know she's a
big fan of yours
so going through the season I I pitched
her on some ideas we settled on you know
it's tough because like you can't you
don't want to like I don't know be
controversial with it like you don't
wanna make anybody mad it's like it got
to be a super specific way that you can
make raise money that works with
compliance and and so the hair was kind
of like what separated me from a lot of
other people and it could be seen from
television and so we said you know with
Chad's favorite color being orange let's
do it and so probably like ten days a
week out we were I mean ever a bunch of
players bought in coach Brown died his
mustache and I think we ended up raising
about 250,000 after was double that well
which is it's crazy
good for you good for you really that
that means that Tanya obviously not just
for your community but to show who a
team would be getting it's not just the
guys are gonna go try and wreck wreck
the play you know you can try and make
the world a better place to when was the
last time you cut your hair so the last
time I mean you get you get trimmed up
and condition and treatments and when
you know you actually get my hair cut
every two weeks believe it or not this
is a high maintenance situation and to
chase one day one day maybe you'll
figure that out but so so it's how often
you what is the maintenance maintenance
is probably about at least once a month
I'll go to like a professional salon and
I'll get it like deep conditioned
treatment yeah so maybe some maintenance
some like site trimming up okay but it's
it's really just about like trying to
wash it it maybe every every other
day-o calm just because you get sweaty
and but it is to pain in the butt
sometimes just a lot of maintenance I
bet I bet he gets knotted up I can see
why old people live short hair he's not
calling you old rich because you are
represented by the same firm that
represents Clay Matthews I am can he
give you tips has he given you tips I'm
so it's funny is actually it was just
like my agency in general athletes first
there you know this place I workout a
proactive they said they had von Miller
and Clay Matthews we're like they're two
more key edge rushers and I said say no
more if like if you want to go and try
to be the best in the game like this is
the agency this is the place you work
out just like for me that's what it was
but yeah we're actually working out a
lot this is in infancy
understood we're trying to get us
something going with Jack Link's
sasquatch and we got a speechless idea
to clay so he sees this you might be a
little upset that I'm saying
but if our vision is kind of like have
Jack Link's and you know he's kind of
like I don't know either like hanging
out with me or whatever and then clay
walks in and he sees Sasquatch and he's
like you know who is this imposter like
why is the ID like this idea I think
there's a germ there's a jackal Zimmer
said okay we can workshop this a little
bit don't worry cuz I'm you know we're
all part of one team we're all part of
one team hey chase good luck to you
thank you keep in touch let's keep it
touch we're now officially in touch
waiting way to play the way that you did
at Michigan and again what you did for
the Chad tough foundation is really
inspiring thank you you bet so check out
chase wina [ __ ] on twitter at chase
underscore wina [ __ ] and on instagram
at win oh okay
at win oh it's not @y no yes anonymously
tag this man with a red flag it's a twin
oh yes here we go and then i'm sorry
about your your waffle crisps sir sorry
when they break that yeah it's rest in
peace okay
but it when it rests in peace it's still
crispy and milk just one of a cheer on
the richezza show the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience